rolling into this morning Saturday
session drive-by truckers the band
formed in Athens Georgia 20 years ago
and they've been exploring the music and
culture of the American South ever since
the new album continues that tradition
with a piercing look at issues of race
and police brutality here two of those
songs in a moment but first i sat down
with founding members Patterson hood and
Mike Cooley at the Gibson guitar
showroom here in New York City
the roots of drive-by truckers go back
to Muscle Shoals Alabama the epicenter
of American rhythm and blues where
founders Patterson hood and Mike Cooley
grew up hoods father David hood is bass
player in the legendary Muscle Shoals
rhythm section I would listen to my
dad's record collection and basically
try to copy the song so high especially
trying to rip off Elton John or whatever
how did it start for you Mike I wanted
to play guitars
as soon as as long as I could remember
Hood and Cooley have been playing
together for 30 years now how did you
guys actually meet we were roommates
well that's pretty fortuitous day the
day at the end I noticed you had a
guitar in the corner and I had a guitar
when we first started playing together
we weren't any good at all but we
already had a kind of there's like a
chemistry about it we played lousy
better together than apart it was a
shared incompetence
so trusted
their first break came in the late 1980s
when their first group called Adams
housecat one musician magazine's
unsigned band contest all that really
did was stunt our growth I think at the
time you know it really did is yeah a
little bit of a kiss of death in a way
why do you think it stunted your growth
we weren't ready to get that kind of
attention yet right yeah we you know
by the time they form drive-by truckers
in 1996 they were determined to make it
on their own terms
and all of a sudden people started
showing up you built your following the
old-fashioned way you just yeah for sure
you just kept going on tour we didn't
have the money coming in to quit our
jobs but we did anyway because we
basically just lived on the road and
starved for you know until it built up
yeah I don't want to do it again but um
I wouldn't take anything for it it was a
great experience yeah tracks the
truckers latest album started coming
together last year after hood was asked
to write an op-ed piece for the New York
Times Magazine did you know what you
wanted to say I knew would have felt it
was just weeks after the mass shootings
of nine African Americans at a
Charleston Church and the Confederate
flag still flew over the South Carolina
Statehouse you know it just felt so
wrong whose essay was titled the South's
heritage is so much more than a flag if
you don't talk about heritage she knows
but you know grandma's cornbread on the
flag why that one up you know or or or
Booker T and the MGS put that on a flag
oh oh
salute that day long day I actually
wrote my first draft of the op-ed I also
wrote a song called darkened flags on
the cusp of dawn
American band is the trucker's eleventh
studio album after 20 years together
they've now played well over 2,000 shows
how do you keep challenging yourselves
every night when you're out there it's
not so much challenging yourself as it
is to still believe in that you're just
getting started I guess I'm just now
getting good at it yeah you know I can't
quit now it's like I'm finally getting
that hearkens you know get the started
yeah